you're
amongst many things a jiu-jitsu black
belt
one of the things that people are really
curious about
white belts and blue belts and jiu-jitsu
but also people haven't tried the art
is what does it take to be a jiu jitsu
black belt
i think that you know everyone's journey
is a little bit different but the one
thing
that the it was the calvin coolidge
quote you know determination persistence
is the only thing
that that will win in the end it will
always win in the end
not brilliance not toughness not
education
it's it's persistence and i think that
having the belief that
no matter what happens to me i will
proceed forward and i will
i will figure out how to make this
happen hell our high water i think is
the one thing that ties together all of
the people that i've ever met
that made it through whatever it was
that they were going through
because you know sometimes you can get
lucky and you can have an easy time
or and that luck could be you had a good
situation it could be i mean like
in the obvious sense of like where
you're living where you're training
what's going on you had a good situation
you're
un unbelievably athletic oh you're
you're going to be an astronaut you're
brilliant and
an olympic athlete you know like well
that's a fantastic situation you know
you won the genetic lottery and i've
worked hard as well but you also won the
genetic lottery it's uh
determination is the one thing though
because that person could
have a very easy go of it initially and
then tear their knee and then they're no
longer the
the superhuman physical specimen that
they were the only thing that will keep
them going
is persistence and i think that that um
i would just say that persistence to say
i'll just put one foot in front of the
other and
sometimes i can see the path ahead and
sometimes it's beyond my vision but i
will not stop
i may even slow down but i won't stop
and
that's the only thing that i can say
that i've seen tie everyone together
because there's so many ways to the top
of any mountain and there's so many
different personalities and skills and
backgrounds involved
but everyone everyone carries on so
at the core the foundational advice is
just don't quit
just keep going that's the lesson of
martial arts i think you know we think
it's like how to be
strong or how to be how to win but in
reality it's like how to persist how to
endure because
it's all of us have been beaten so many
times and gotten beaten up so many times
and thought about quitting have i ever
thought about quitting absolutely have i
ever quit never
i will never ever quit ever i can say
you might not me i will be
damned if i quit what's the darkest
moment is it injury related like
is that is it uh so like
to me like two possibilities i've
fortunately never been
seriously injured but i think that's a
dark place to be
like having to be out for many months
for um as general saying like with a
head injury especially
like the uncertainty that's one
and then the other side is if you have
big ambitions as a competitor realizing
that you're not
as good like those those doubts were
like
i kind of suck how am i supposed to be a
world
the greatest fighter of all time if i if
if like several people in the gym are
kicking my ass
those are the two things that paralyzing
i think
that everyone's darkest moment is maybe
different
looking from the outside for ryan i
wouldn't say that he's had injuries and
he said bad ones i wouldn't say that was
his darkest moment
i think for me i would say some my head
injury was my darkest moment
absolutely and i have torn my acl twice
i've torn my shoulders four times i've
had lots of surgeries
for me the orthopedic injuries were not
the most
difficult it was the brain injury for
others that might be the case for them
maybe they've never
experienced an injury and maybe for them
that's their darkest moment
from the outside obviously orion can
speak to this more but for ryan i think
it was the
um inability to to perform at certain
points to the opera
the missing of opportunities that for
him from my perspective watching him go
through and having seen
various points of his growth from from
early purple bought on
i think the hardest time for him looking
in obviously was
when he would hit moments where he
wasn't able to perform
for various reasons he couldn't get
fights he was having difficulties there
i think that
that was the hardest point for him did
you did you think
like with a head injury that you might
not never be able to do jiu jitsu again
yeah i mean i i mine was very um
it was really bad and it was just the
one hit but i had a looping memories for
seven months
didn't know it because when your brain's
messed up you're not even aware that
you're looping
um and so uh i saw two different
neurologists i find like it took a very
long time
um i didn't know if i was going to be
able to have like linear thoughts or
read a book i didn't know at certain
points if i could listen to music again
you know without it making my head hurt
and so
it was almost two years before i woke up
in the morning without a headache
um just waking up before i even start my
day and so that so that's even bigger
than jiu jitsu that's just life
that's just that's just hard and i think
that
you can experience so many things i've
had all these injuries
we lost the baby when i was 15 15 weeks
and we've had all these experiences and
what the hardest point for me
not saying all those things weren't hard
but it's kind of like
as you go through these you just realize
like life goes on and you have to keep
working at it and you have to keep going
and
you asked me earlier offline did i feel
depressed and
not from my head injury i don't think
that at least in the moment i had a
any recognition of that it's kind of
like but i think different people's
personalities i have kind of the like
buckle down and just keep going and
sometimes it's not until
lots of time later that you realize wow
that was really hard
because you're just struggling to live
and and function and do the things that
you need to do alone do you mind
jumping on just like this part of the
conversation just for a few minutes it's
over
do you mind you know just sitting
together oh no no
yeah just for a little bit be cool be
cool so we put a face to it you know
uh is it okay with you yeah it's fine
with me if it's fine with you
by the way what was the head injury if
you don't mind sharing
someone hit there had dropped their knee
on the back of my head during training
who's
a lot bigger than me so one
strike to the back of the head is too
much for
some there's a reason that's outlawed in
mma right someone 50 pounds everything
you drop their knee on the back your
head once and it's
that's the funny thing about getting hit
right you never can really be sure
what's going to happen
i think that's actually one of the
magical parts about jiu jitsu where like
if you choke me
if you we know what's going to occur
you hit someone they might be completely
unharmed like you might be punching tony
ferguson in the face and like
you need to hit him with a sledgehammer
to affect this man and then other people
they
could get really badly hurt which i
guess it's back to your point about you
know street fighting and things like
that and the
serious serious potential you know
second third order consequences of any
action that we take
but yeah that's a that's a tricky thing
about getting hit how does it make you
feel that
like the the really shitty thing about
injuries to me
was that like you start thinking like
well if i did
this one little thing different like
this wouldn't have happened today
like one one moment changes your entire
life
is that do you uh do you think that
where is that
totally counterproductive um you can't
help but think that way
when you've had the amount of injuries
i've had now because i've had more than
most people's fair share um as my
orthopedic says you don't want to win
that
you don't want to with the contest of
who's had the most but since you haven't
built me a pool yeah um but
i think you can't help but think that
way sometimes but i definitely don't
think it's
i think it can be facilitated if you
don't beat yourself up too much
um because thinking about
why have i been subject to so many
injuries and
and a lot of it comes to just um
almost all of mine in particular people
a lot heavier than me so we're talk
but if i've been training martial arts
15 years i'm obviously on the much
smaller side i'm a woman
i've done thousands and thousands of
rounds
with people 50 pounds plus heavier than
me i mean years
not training with anyone less than 500
which is 50 pounds is almost half my
body weight
and when you also add testosterone the
natural
physiological advantages of men not just
are they heavier with more mass they're
faster they're more explosive they're
stronger
if they're the same size and so i think
that the willingness to be in that
environment over and over and over again
creates a lot of
strength resiliency willingness to
continue but it also
like in order to do that you almost have
to
uh for me the way i was approaching was
like pretend like i wasn't
more vulnerable and just be willing to
step in and step in and stuff take it
until you make it kind of
until you make it kind of yeah like i'll
just one day i'll be strong enough
and you avoid an injury for most from
most of those rounds i would injure
the problem as ryan points out is that
like you could do thousands of rounds
but if one person that size that
strength that
however reacts in a way that you don't
expect it doesn't
it's not like an oops it's like always
major do you regret
any of it like i think that most no one
i know has experienced the degree
of injuries that i've experienced and i
started juice at a time when
in 2005 is very different than now where
you have the coaches have more control
over what you're doing they're more
aware in general about a lot of the
injuries there's a lot
more people who are uh
hobbyists than when i started um they
were hobbyists but it was different kind
of hobbyist you know then now
now our girls can train with other girls
they don't have to do thousands
of rounds with somebody significantly
more powerful than them
and for the drawbacks and the benefits
of that you know as with anything
so i think i think that
i don't think i would go back and change
it there were times after one of my
injuries where
i said to ryan i said i quit i'm done
i'm not doing this anymore i probably
said it more than once but there was one
time i was really serious in 2012.
i was really serious i tore my shoulder
i had i was looking at missing a big
competition again the world's
for my second or third year in a row
after injuries and i said
i'd quit my job two years before and i'm
like
i'm done and run before that had always
been you know
keep me focused and then he kind of said
okay if you want to be done be done
just just have a good time no i'm i'm
really done i don't want to train
anymore
okay okay and then you know i think he
helped facilitate
a moment for me to go um visit a friend
some friends some girls that were doing
a girls camp
who were close to my size or some
friends of mine to go train and i was
like oh wait
i do love this thing it's harder for me
on a daily basis but that doesn't mean i
don't love this thing
and it really helped change my mind i
started to connect with some other
people
travel more myself because previously he
had done that but
i hadn't really done that i think there
was a point where
um when i started youtube it was just
for fun i just wanted to sport after
college i played sports as a kid i want
to i just want to exercise i wasn't into
the martial arts
he usually gave me a hard time about it
because he was always very big how can
you not care about martial
i don't know i just want to play sports
um
and ryan was really big into kind of the
philosophy side of the martial arts
aspect
um he used to give me a hard time and i
think after that moment this moment
where i looked at myself and i said do i
want to keep doing this
is when i started to appreciate
jiu-jitsu take it took off some of the
pressure i'd been feeling i think as
ryan's
girlfriend but i had a full-time job a
long time it was never my goal to be a
jiu jitsu world champion
and i think after that moment where i
like you know i really do like this i
really do want to
just i had this moment like any time
where you're like i'm doing this for me
i'm not doing this
for him and i think that that's um i
think
that was really lucky for me because
how often in our lives do we have a kind
of a challenge where we have to stop and
we have to say is this really what i
want
how often in a relationship do you do
that how often in any type of
lifestyle or job do you stop and you
really ask yourself is something really
difficult happen that you look and you
go am i just doing this because it's
convenient and easy or is this what i
really want to do
yeah i've had those moments like this
this podcast is one of those things
it's like you you stop and think like
i actually love this and it's uh i had
that with jiu-jitsu too
i don't think i had until like brown
belt did i
stop i mean yeah it's when you first
face real challenges
you think like why am i doing this it's
i think most
of my progression was why not i think
that's the right the leap of faith
and then at a certain point you think
like
what why am i doing this and if you can
answer
honestly that because i love it it's
kind of a liberating feeling
it's a it's a yeah it's so it's so
powerful
thankful for the opportunity to be there
right because you love it and yeah man
yeah great gratitude it's yeah it's it's
ultimately gratitude
yeah let me ask you this so you ryan
said like
what what did i took over your thing
yeah this is no no nobody cares
about ryan i wouldn't yeah i'll i'll
photoshop him out or whatever however
you had to do that be great
just put sean connery's head just like a
dune add
exactly
is that the sexiest man in sean connery
in the dune universe that's my
understanding
okay i think in any universe yeah well
ryan gosling given we actually named our
son after sean connery
oh yeah that's right yes
[Laughter]
he was in the rock those i i love all
those great lame
nicholas cage oh yeah conairs facebook
greatest movie
time air was so awesome
i don't know where it's from alabama i
guess or something well they got like
steve buscemi in there like we need
steve buscemi in this thing you know we
got him
dave chappelle yeah that's right yeah
he's a prisoner
eight ball yep greatest movie of all
time
should have won enough dave chappelle
also in blue streak with martin lawrence
and then uh what do you call it uh robin
hood men in tights oh robin
was one of my favorites as a kid i've
baked but rob yeah
that's a good uh wow
we just listed off some really bad 90s
movies but you take that back
we're telling our age yeah you're so bad
ask yourself
so what um like in your view i don't
mean to
from like a smaller person i guess
that's an interesting thing while
jiu-jitsu is like
that uh small i don't
hopefully that's not a bad thing um
like with all these like uh bigger
people you can still enjoy the art like
what does it take to get a black belt
to excel to quote unquote master the art
gosh everyone has such a different path
brian's promoted
six seven people something like that and
i think about half of them
have had um
have kids have families have other
careers
at the time some of them competed a lot
some of them have never
competed or rarely competed some have
been competing a long time
some had started different places
everyone's had different journeys
even in our own little group of seven
i think only maybe only two or three
were
were high-level competitors of that
group
um at the higher belts very like brown
black maybe
um and so that's just different for
every person and that's something that
that you know we try to tell her since
we have 400 students
and um do we have us we don't really
have anyone who's
you know a stated other other than like
the coaches like adam but we don't have
anyone that's like a stated high level
competitor as a student at the moment we
people look at our gym like oh there's
lots of competitors there's not lots of
competitors it's never been
lots of competitors and we've had ones
and twos here and there
um but really everybody's in it for the
long term if they're in it
sometimes the high level competitors are
the ones that are more likely to drop
off because they
have a bit of success particularly at
blue or purple and then they realize how
hard it is at brown and black and then
they they have a hard time continuing
on that that path and then they can't
look at themselves as a non-competitive
hard time continuing with jiu jitsu i
think
whereas sometimes it's the guy who comes
in as the white belt and he trains
you know twice a week every week and the
next thing you know he's been there for
two or three years like oh he's a blue
belt he's a purple
he's a brown belt and and he's just
consistent over over
a long period of time and willing to
take the path
and no two people's path is exactly the
same no two people's lives are exactly
the same
you have um we have students who started
as a white belt as
you know a young adult with no you know
no responsibilities and they train all
the time and then they
have a job you know then they graduate
college then they have a job then they
have married then they have kids then
they have different points in their
careers and at different points in your
life
jiu jitsu will be there you know for
whatever way that you're willing to
accept it
it's place i think well that's actually
kind of what
back to the initial question we
discussed about you know what makes a
warrior
you know and also like what makes
something or someone you know
particularly impressive in my mind
is like uh what they make out of what
they have
um you know one of my favorite movies
ever as far as gump and it's obviously
it's it's just
if you can't because i've heard people
doing forrest gump sucks i'm like i
don't like you as a person
and uh like you have no heart at all
but basically uh it's the story of
someone that tries hard and it's like
yeah
but it's it's funny movie but it's like
um you know i guess
you meet each person where they are you
know and
obviously you want everyone needs to be
pushed we all need to be pushed we need
friends and people around us that push
us to be better versions of ourselves
all the time and as you mentioned the
people you spend all of your time around
deeply impact you um and we have to be
willing to be pushed it takes a leap of
faith for me to trust
me to put some of my self in my
my you know i guess my ability my
control my personal agency as it were in
the hands of someone else
that i that i trust and and that i
respect but
if if i can do that again maybe i never
become
you know high-level black belt
competitor but you know i had four of
the things i was doing my life i also
have a family i have this i have that
you know what that person was able to
accomplish in the martial arts relative
to what they were able to put in this
phenomenal
you know other times someone could be a
very successful black belt and it might
might be a bum
because they could have been a lot more
and you know they could have done more
they could have focused more
and there's no shame in deciding that
you don't want to do that but whatever
it is that you're
you're invested in i remember the uh
take it uneasy podcast and that
i loved because you know i'll just chill
out i like resting it's like vacation oh
who wants to go on vacation you know go
on vacation for day or two you want to
spend three weeks on vacation like i
kill myself like get me out of here like
this is horrible
this is i'm i'm a waste of life i'm not
doing anything useful right now
technically application right now
right well this is fun though it's like
a one-day vacation yeah exactly but
you know that is if you had i'm sure
you're thinking about jumping off of the
building right now but if you had to if
you had to talk to me for you know like
uh three days i'm sure you died
you'd probably shut me off the building
i don't blame you i would be dead but
yeah five hours in
but yeah but you know it's like you want
to be pushing towards something
um because otherwise what's the purpose
of being here you know it's not just a
college
it's doing something useful building
growing as a person helping others do
the same if that's within your power
at any given time but i think that's
kind of the neat thing about martial
arts is it can be many many different
things to many different people
you know i finally for instance was able
to get a college degree le this this
year
that which i mean it's not a big deal
for most people but for me it was a big
deal because i was
going back and finish yeah and i never
envisioned ever going back
and that's a hard step to to go back and
finish that's uh
it it weighs heavy on you if you don't
it's interesting yeah i was just
i was more proud of that than most
things i've ever done if i'm honest you
know and
it was neat and i really enjoyed it and
it was the process of doing it but
you know are my academic credentials
impressive like not in the least
but for me it's like it was a big deal
for me personally to take that step
and to to go back and do that and i was
i was proud of the
the direction and because it would have
been easy like do i need to do it like
no i'm you know
business i'll do okay i'll try i'll keep
fighting but i
i was happy to take the time in between
fights when i was when i would
was unbooked for an opponent to do
something productive rather than just
i'll just hang out you know like i can
still train every single day but i can
also train and go to school
people go to the olympics while going to
school i can i can do martial arts
and go to school
you